♪ ♪
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO PROTECT
LIFE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO DEFEND
THOSE WHO CAN'T DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THIS WILL REPRESENT THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PROTECTIONS FOR LIFE
THAT HAD BEEN ENACTED IN THIS
STATE IN A GENERATION.
>> Laura: THAT WAS
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS TO GO WEEKS
AGO SIGNING A LAW THAT PROHIBITS
ABORTION AFTER 15 WEEKS UNLESS
THE MOTHER'S LIFE IS AT RISK OR
THE BABY WILL SUFFER FROM A
FATAL ABNORMALITY.
THAT LEGISLATION WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO MY NEXT GUEST.
AFTER SUFFERING A STROKE WHILE
PREGNANT WITH HER OLDER SISTER,
DOCTORS IN HER FAMILY ARE
PRESENTED HER MOM HAVE AN
ABORTION WHEN SHE WAS PREGNANT
WITH HER, THAT ADVICE DIDN'T SIT
RIGHT WITH HER AND SHE MADE A
COURAGEOUS DIVISION TO GO
THROUGH WITH A VERY DIFFICULT
PREGNANCY.
THAT DECISION INFORMED HER
POSITION ON LIFE AND SHE IS NOW
THE LEADER OF THE HOUSE PRO-LIFE
CAUCUS -- GOD IS GOOD.
ALSO WITH US IS CARRIE KELLOGG,
A FLORIDA MOM WHO ADOPTED A
LITTLE GIRL NAMED HOPE AFTER SHE
SURVIVED AN ATTEMPTED ABORTION
AT JUST TEN AND A HALF WEEKS
GESTATION.
UNBELIEVABLE STORY, WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU.
SOMETHING THE ABORTION FIGHT IS
LOSING, THEY THINK IT'S LOSING
ONE FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
YOUR RESPONSE TO YOUNG VOTERS,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG WOMEN WHO HAVE
BEEN FED SO MANY LIES ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
>> I HAVE TO THINK ABOUT AS THE
YOUNGEST WERE PUBLIC AND WOMEN
IN CONGRESS TODAY, I STAND HERE
BASICALLY AN ABORTION SURVIVOR
AND ON THE CUSP OF BEING AMONGST
THE GENERATION THAT IS
POST-ROE V. WADE.
MILLENNIALS ARE THE PRO-LIFE
GENERATION, THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
WANT TO THINK ABOUT HOW THE LEFT
HAS REALLY CORNERED THE MARKET,
EFFECTIVELY SHADOW BANNING THE
PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT THROUGH BIG
TECH, THROUGH MEDIA, THEY HAVE
HAD EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO TELL
THE FACTS AND TELL THE TRUTH BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FACTS AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TRUTH.
THOSE OF US IN THE PRO-LIFE
MOVEMENT DO.
WE HAVE SCIENCE ON OUR SIDE, WE
HAVE GOD ON OUR SIDE AND WE WILL
BE VICTORIOUS AND END
ROE V. WADE.
>> Laura: YOUR STORY IS SUCH A
POWERFUL ONE, WHEN I FIRST READ
ABOUT YOU AND YOUR DAUGHTER, I
AM A MOM OF AN ADOPTED DAUGHTER
AND TWO ADOPTED SONS.
YOUR STORY WAS SO MOVING, I GET
TEARED UP THINKING ABOUT IT.
BRIEFLY RECAP WHY YOU MADE THE
DECISION YOU DID AND WHY PEOPLE
SHOULD PAY ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE NOW.
>> WHEN WE DECIDED WE WANTED TO
ADOPT, I WAS GOING TO BE A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER, I WAS
OPEN TO SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN
AND I KNEW THEY WERE HARD TO
PLACE.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS OPEN TO WHEN I
HEARD ABOUT HER CHRISTIAN
ADOPTION AGENCY.
>> Laura: YOU WERE CALLED TO
DO THIS.
>> SHE HAS BEEN A BLESSING, IT'S
BEEN WHAT WE KNOW AND IT HAS
BEEN DIFFICULT, BEING A MOTHER
IS DIFFICULT TO COME.
BUT THE BLESSINGS HAVE FAR
OUTWEIGHED -- GOD HAS OPENED
DOORS FOR US TO SHARE OUR STORY
WHICH TAKES A LOT FOR SOMEONE TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
AND WHEN WE SHARE IT -- WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER HEAD?
WE TELL PEOPLE WHEN SHE WAS TEN
WEEKS GESTATION WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE SIZE OF THIS BABY,
FIRST TRIMESTER, THAT'S WHEN HER
BIRTH MOM WENT AND HAD AN
ABORTION.
SHE LEFT NOT KNOWING SHE WAS
STILL PREGNANT AND SHE FELT
MOVEMENT AT FIVE AND A HALF
MONTHS.
THEN SHE CHOSE LIFE, SHE CHOSE
ADOPTION AND DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING WAS WRONG WITH HER AND
SHE DELIVERED EARLY, THEY KNEW
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE TO PLACE
HER WITH A SPECIAL NEEDS
ADOPTION AGENCY.
>> Laura: THERE ARE ANGELS ON
EARTH WALKING AMONG US AND I
THINK YOU ARE ONE OF THEM AND
HOPE IS HERE TONIGHT.
I'M SO GLAD YOU ARE HERE, YOU
ARE A WITNESS, A LIVING WITNESS
TO THE EVILS THAT WE CAN AVOID
BY CHOOSING THE RIGHT THING, WHY
IS THIS SO IMPORTANT AND WHY DO
PEOPLE NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS?
>> I THINK BECAUSE PEOPLE, NEED
TO CHOOSE LIFE FOR THEIR CHILD,
EVEN THOUGH IT MAY NOT BE EASY,
THEY CHOOSE LIFE FOR THEIR CHILD
BECAUSE FOR ME, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS GOING THROUGH UNTIL
GOD SENT A VERY SPECIAL PERSON
IN MY LIFE AND THAT SPECIAL
PERSON IS MY MOTHER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: CONGRESSWOMAN,
HERE'S WHAT ONE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD DOCTOR SAID ABOUT
LAWS SUCH AS WHAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS PAST
YESTERDAY IN OKLAHOMA, PAST THE
SIX WEEK ABORTION BAN MODELED ON
WHAT TEXAS DID COME OF THIS IS
WHAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS
TRYING TO SELL.
>> YOU ARE MAKING IT SO THAT
PEOPLE OF LOW INCOME CANNOT
OBTAIN ABORTIONS.
YOU ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
CONTROLLING PEOPLE THAT ARE
BLACK AND BROWN, LIKE I SAID,
LOW INCOME.
A LAW THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> Laura: FOR MORE BLACK AND
BROWN BABIES TO BE BORN IS NOW
BY THAT LOGIC I'M A RACIST?
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW THE LEFT CAN
SPIN ANYTHING.
THEY PERPETUATE A CULTURE OF
VICTIMHOOD BUT WE IN THIS ROOM,
PEOPLE ACROSS AMERICA KNOW THAT
VICTIMHOOD IS NOT A VIRTUE, IT
IS A CONDITION.
IF THEY WERE SMART IN PARTICULAR
THAT DR. WE JUST HEARD, THEY
WERE RECOGNIZE THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WAS FOUNDED BY
SOMEONE WHO CHAMPIONED EUGENICS.
THE NUMBER ONE RACE THAT IS
TERMINATED IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
BLACK BABIES IN THE PRO-LIFE
MOVEMENT IS ABOUT EMPOWERMENT,
IT'S ABOUT EMPOWERING WOMEN,
IT'S ABOUT GIVING A VOICE TO
THOSE LITTLE GIRLS WERE GOING TO
BE ABORTED AND THAT GOES FOR THE
WHITE A LITTLE GIRLS, BLACK
LITTLE GIRLS COME AROUND LITTLE
GIRLS, WE DON'T SEE COLOR IN THE
PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT.
IT'S A REAL SLAP IN THE FACE TO
EVERY SINGLE PERSON, MAN AND
WOMAN WHO HAS CHAMPIONED AND
ADVOCATED THE VOICE OF PREBORN
CHILDREN.
IT IS A SHAME IN THE LEFT KNOWS
THIS IS A LOSING ISSUE BECAUSE
THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT, WE ARE
WINNING.
>> Laura: THE LEFT WOULD SAY
THAT HOPE WAS NOT HUMAN WHEN
THEY ATTEMPTED TO ABORT.
SHE WASN'T HUMAN.
HUMAN, HEART, VOICE, LOVE.
MOTHER'S DAY IS COMING UP, I CAN
THINK OF A BETTER SEGMENT THAT
WE COULD HAVE DONE AND I'M GOING
TO START BAWLING, WE HAVE TO GET
OUT.
THANK YOU, TERRY, THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING OUT, THANK YOU
CONGRESSWOMAN, YOU ARE THE
FUTURE OF THIS PARTY AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU